wow
[Applause]
crying Kelly Clarkson's brought to tears
on the voice but she's not the only one
crying that was so good thank you so
much you really touched my heart it's a
good season Reba McIntyre joins the
singing competition as season 23's Mega
Mentor it's her first time back since
mentoring Team Blake during season one
Reba was the person that I looked to the
most as I was trying to make it in
country music look at this we look like
babies
oh my God
during knockout round rehearsal
special contestant tugged at Reba's
heartstrings as Team Blake singer Kylie
Dane wowed with a rendition of Celine
Dion's all by myself
she was real cute real shy and I thought
well she's gonna have a little bitty
voice probably wrong
that was so good thank you so much you
really touched my heart that's the
biggest thing is to capture somebody in
the audience to where they're sobbing or
laughing get some emotion out of them
and you did it for me then for coach
Kelly the Waterworks came when her
newest team member Carla banham
rehearsed for her performance of The Goo
Goo Dolls Iris
[Music]
to see me
Paula first came on I thought wow the
emotion that she showed I got chills
Kelly cried and that's what you want
from a performer wow
[Applause]
that feels a great story when you sing
call us surprised me most she can make
you cry
um after the first three notes that's
rare but really emotions are high all
around as Blake Shelton set to wrap up
his 12-year run as a coach on the
competition series that's it I'm never
going to beg somebody to be on my team
again I'm never going to hit this button
again it's probably going to be an
emotional night that last night I mean
my God it's been 23 see 12 years I kind
of want to be the one to kick him out
the door but also I want to hug him
while he's going it's I have mixed
feelings as for who's taking Blake's
coveted red chair that's still TBD but
we know a country crooner who would be
just right for the job I still like to
be busy I like to be around people I
like to work with people
I like to do television I love music so
yeah Reba likes to keep it moving and
shaken but she told E.T earlier this
year it's probably not in the cards you
said that you passed on the opportunity
first now here's here's the thing I'm
trying to manifest something here Blake
is hanging up his hat at the voice
they're gonna need to fill that red seat
would you be down to do it now at this
point or would you pass again who could
feel like shoes well I can't see me
doing that because you know I'm a gypsy
at heart to do that for five months it
was just like I don't think I'll ever be
able to do it but to feel Blake's chair
wow that's going to be tough
he did a great job in kudos to him
[Music]